but first here's my brain done
vladimir putin invaded ukraine to show
the russian people and the world how big
and strong he and his military are a
global heavyweight that could bullies
neighbors into submission punch its way
to domination
but instead humiliatingly for the
increasingly isolated tin pot dictator
he's showing us all the complete
opposite against all the odds putin's
now on the ropes smack to the canvas by
staggeringly brave ukrainian resistance
and his own tactical stupidity don't
take my word for it even retired
colonels on russia's state tv which
spews out endless kremlin propaganda and
now admitting they're on the back foot
lord
the main deficiency of our military
political position is that in a way we
are in full geopolitical isolation and
that however much we would hate to admit
it virtually the entire world is against
us and it's that situation that we need
to get out of
it's hard to wear the state just how
significant that kind of comment is in a
country where any public criticism of
putin usually ends very badly for the
person saying it but all the evidence
suggests it's true and desperate putin
is now personally making decisions
normally made by his colonels maybe
because so many of his actual colonels
at least 40 have been killed in the war
so far along with 27 000 troops a third
of putin's entire invasion force
and then there were smoldering skeletons
of 650 russian tanks and 3 000 armored
vehicles
all a striking reminder of their leaders
military missteps
now of course it's far too early and
optimistic to suggest that ukraine is
winning the toughest bouts undoubtedly
lie ahead as putin tries to maul as well
of a defeat he knows could finish him
but nobody gave ukrainians a hope in
hell when the russian forces invaded 82
long days ago so the fact they are where
they are today is astonishing and
testament to their incredible fighting
spirit and instead of scaring off nato
as putin helped the invasion hoped
the invasion has actually made russian
neighbors like finland and sweden
abandoned decades of neutrality to join
the alliance
so putin's got support from much of the
world
he's strengthened nato and now he's
losing support inside russia i'm not i
speak to the boxing champion now helping
to inspire ukraine's astonishing
comeback it's time that the west ramped
up its efforts to help them deliver the
knockout blow
[Music]
it's that word that can't be spoken
it can be alluded to but never actually
said
suggested but always censored
of course it's the w word
inconveniently it refers to about fifty
percent of the world's population
but fortunately all inclusive linguistic
innovators have come up with many
alternatives which are apparently a lot
less offensive than the w word
birthing people
menstruators
bodies with vaginas
individuals with a cervix
chest feeders
these are all real by the way and then
there's this one
once woman ex women's woman nixon
womacks i have no idea i don't know how
you pronounce that do you
former first lady michelle obama used it
on her instagram at the weekend
ironically to promote women's rights
over abortion one of the slides she
shared said state lawmakers will have
some power to strip womanics of the
right to make decisions about their
bodies and their healthcare
now those who watch the show last night
will know we had some issues with
offensive language so i will say the
following word with some trepidation
it's woman
michelle
woman
there's no ex in woman
what makes this particularly absurd is
that mrs obama's post was supposed to be
supporting women's rights instead she's
trampled on them by pandering to a tiny
minority of people who get upset when
they hear a word that's been used for
centuries to describe people who aren't
men
the term womanics whatever it is
is supposed to be a mark of respect i'm
told for transgender and non-binary
people who identify as women but what
about the mark of disrespect that it
shows to the vast vast majority of women
who would just like to be called women
spelt that way
w-o-m-e-n
are their rights in all this virtue
signaling language mangling reducing
half of the world's population to an
unpronounceable letter salad does
nothing but deride women and draws
mockery to the trans cause
michelle obama of all people should have
known better than to fuel this nonsense
well sometimes new stories are so absurd
they look more like satirical parodies i
honestly thought somebody was winding me
up when i saw a headline the spice girl
turned fashion designer victoria beckham
had declared that wanting to be thin is
an old-fashioned attitude women today
want to look healthy and curvy she told
a glossy magazine as she unveiled her
new collection
to which i say sorry what
is this the same victoria beckham
notorious for literally eating a salad
leaf for lunch
and the same victoria beckham more
pertinently who puts on catwalk shows
with models like this
for many years she has deliberately used
skeletal gaunt hollow cheat models to
flog her fashion
which i regularly criticize as a
horribly dangerous inspiration to the
tens of millions of young girls who
follow victoria beckham on social media
and i suspect this sudden you turn to
celebrating curvier bodies is more
connected to her struggling business
which has lost millions and never made a
profit
than about her dramatic conversion to
the aesthetic charms of the larger lady
as this latest cover of sports
illustrated shows bigger is the new
thinner and where all the fascia money
is now going
meanwhile these are the women currently
modeling victoria beckham's new vb body
range
i've seen more curves on a roman road so
stick a cork in your body positive
preaching posh i see right through the
very little of you
now there are three things in life that
are absolutely nailed down certain death
taxes and snowflakes complaining about
me we knew when we recorded the tv
advert for this show poking fun at the
oversensitive work brigade there would
immediately be a wave of frenzy protests
from the oversensitive work brigade and
right on queue in they came with formal
complaints lots to be advertising
standards authority which is the uk's ad
regulator by po people moaning about how
deeply offended they are well this is
the deeply offensive and triggering
promo that we ran
welcome to piers morgan on sunset it's
my new show where people can speak their
minds sorry peers some people don't
identify as people
it's a place for big opinions sorry
that's fattest for me to debate
offensive for vegans
the world's gone nuts nuts could be
sexist and offensive actually i find you
offensive mate
38 people
watched that and was so distressed by
what they watched that they felt they
had to make
an official complaint they said the ad
was offensive
as it was targeting marginalized
communities and making light of the
discrimination that they face
a number of complainers objected
particularly to the some people don't
identify as people like can you imagine
complaining about that
fortunately
common sense prevailed the authority
rejected these complaints
it was a victory for free speech for
sanity and in
fact common sense as piers morgan
now remains uncensored and will always
remain uncensored
you